and for brett phillips today a bit of a
homecoming since phillips was traded
from kansas city to the rays with a
lefty on the mount phillips not starting
tonight but he did have some fun with
salvador perez he won a little bet
against prez in the off season over who
would win the super bowl so perez today
wore a tom brady jersey during batting
practice on the other side today it's
danny duffy he's allowed just one total
run in two starts he goes for the kansas
city royals this is his third start of
the season
and up comes brandon lau
now fighting a slump his average
down to 176.
he's homered once he's driven in six
brandon one out of seven
in the raised series
against the
yankees right down the middle
danny duffy strikes out two
and lau was just locked up
so one two three two strikeouts at the
end of half an inning
to raise nothing the royals are coming
up it is josh fleming starting in the
mount for tampa bay this is a homecoming
of sorts for josh he will have 40 or so
family and friends on hand at kauffman
stadium
that brings up solaire
solaire hitting 167 with seven hits and
one home run
now the pitch on its way swinging a
ground ball off the end of the bat to
the second baseman brandon low he'll
throw to first and plenty of time and
that will
retire the side so the royals gonna man
aboard get him all the way to third
but can't get him in
that brings up hunter dozier
there's a ground ball second out at
second and the throw to first
in time to complete the double play and
it goes four to six to three now brandon
lowell
now the one-two swing and a miss struck
him out another good fastball well
located low outside corner so that's
999 strikeouts
for danny duffy
two out bases empty for
manuel margot
crowd picks up a bid here at kauffman
stadium hoping duffy can get the
strikeout
the 3-2
swung on him there it is
1 000 strikeouts for danny duffy in his
career
we head to the bottom of the fourth
inning of play here at kaufman stadium
it's the royals nothing and the raise
nothing now we'll bring up the number
eight hitter they're
right-handed hitting shortstop willie
adamus another young player he's 24.
flight out to center fielder michael
taylor his first time up he's two for
his last 25 they really like his defense
and they feel bullish about his ability
long term
as here's the pitch to will he swings
and pops it up
center of the diamond now actually to
the right of the diamond i should say
and the first baseman santana dancing
with it and he missed it he missed it
and he throws the ball in the left field
adamus is safe at second base and coming
around third and scoring is wendell and
the race take a one nothing lead
on a missed play by the royals
more than one misplay
that was two misplays
this looks to be as routine as you're
gonna get
not only does he not catch it he whiffs
it
i don't know if that ball caught glove
at all
and if it did it wasn't much
yeah it it nicked the thumb
what a break for the raise
kumar fly to center his first time up
runner at second base race with a one
nothing lead now in the fifth inning
as duffy gets the sign and now the
left-hander
comes set
and the pitch on its way
slashed down the left field line that's
going to get down for a hit ben attendee
over to go get it adam has stumbled a
bit around third but he can maintain his
footing and gets home to score and it's
an rbi base it for kevin kiermeier and
the rays take a two nothing lead here in
the fifth
and there's a timely hit against a guy
who's not giving up much tonight
lefty on lefty sliced to the opposite
side and into a perfect place and with
two outs adamus
easily able to score and attend he's got
a pretty good arm but no chance at him
that will bring up michael a taylor who
flight out to shallow right his first
time michael is two for 20 on the home
stand
and out there cutting the miss
he got him to chase it and that'll do it
for kansas city here in the fifth a nice
one two three clean inning for josh
fleming and the bases are full for
francisco mejia
the runners take their lead the pitch by
duffy a chopper back to the mound danny
comes home sal goes to first base double
play
well done and danny duffy shouts to the
heavens
as he bumped chest with salvador perez
in celebration
a one two three double play gets the
royals out of a jam still the rays have
the lead two nothing going to the bottom
of the sixth
both corners are in as they're expecting
kier meyer to bunt
down ball tonight's going to get beneath
the glove
of the second baseman merrifield here
comes wendell in the score and the rays
tack on a run it's three to nothing
fairfield is trying to backhand that
ball and it stayed down on him
brandon low the batteries 0 for three
zuber's first pitch swung on hit in the
air deep to center taylor going back
still going back under it now makes the
catch
great job by tyler zuber
gets diaz rosarina and lau the royals
still in it trailing three-nothing as we
head to the bottom of inning number
seven the whitmer field is coming up as
the possible tying run
field has been locked out to this point
he is grounded out twice
and flied out to right field
two balls two strikes to whitmer field
runners lead at first and third with two
out strickland on top now throws
swinging at a miss he struck him out he
got a fastball by their field and that
is not easy to do
and mirrorfield is over four and the
royals are stymied here in the eighth
the battery will be kevin kiermeier
and the pitch to kiermeier swings and
lines it back through the middle into
center field for a base hit
williams will come in and score the
raise to indeed get a little insurance
and now have a four nothing lead in
kansas city
so here's brandon
he's over four in the game today
dave is ready and then comes the 3-2
pitch
foul tip and hell that's a strikeout
when the inning is over
the rays add one we go to the bottom of
the ninth four to nothing tampa bay
carlos santana
will lead off for the royals santana
has two of the four royals hits
and a 2-2 is ripped and caught by lau
and he had to get a little hang time
there it was hit right to him but he
surely had to jump
and now solaire
he has struck out twice and grounded out
to second base
two tube delivery is
hit high in the air
left center field
keermeyer is there to make the catch
perez heads home the throw home
will not be in time and the royals have
busted the shutout
now the batter
is alberto anzer alberto is 0 for two he
was nicked by a pitch
his first time up
in field back to 2-0 swaying and he
popped him up right side now into foul
territory brasso along the wall makes
the catch in the raise win
so the rays
go into kansas city and take game one of
this three-game series